we are in the middle of war I need your
help to win it
seems fairly a Dilek for wartime no one
knows it's happened yet or that it's
already been lost
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie bring
yourself back online this is gonna be my
Westworld season 3 episode 2 video if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
a bunch of Easter eggs couple big cameo
scenes too careful for spoilers if you
have not seen the episode yet will do
top 10 WTF and easter eggs as we go
along starting with number 10
welcome to war world so the episode
begins with me looking out on the world
world park scene it takes her a while to
figure out what's going on but they
tried to play a lot of the season 1
season 2 tropes in really funny
different way this time a simulation
within a simulation boom mind blown you
notice a lot of funny things during this
first loop she's not sure why she knows
how to speak German but we know that she
does have special powers but later when
she and Hector are running out and
trying to escape the Germans she finds
out that her powers aren't working takes
her a little while to find out why but
they explained it by the end of the
episode even though this wound up being
a fake version of the part because it's
artificial construct and them trying to
get information out of earth they were
trying to base it on the real version of
war world so there is a real war world
within the larger park system remember
there's many different parks we haven't
seen them all yet we saw two new ones
during this episode number 9 welcome
back to West world Bernard the funny
thing about the way he enters the park
we finally get to see what it actually
looks like on the outside when someone
physically travels to West world because
we've only seen them come in on the
train before in the West World Park you
have to remember that it's actually a
bunch of different islands within the
South China Sea so if you wondered why
there was so much China stuff going on
in last week's episode that's because
this is where the park is located within
the world we've seen them looking out
over the coast but we never actually
seen the outer rim so you just see these
giant breakers here with systems that'll
look like they're built to protect the
park the place that he walks in through
though is also really important because
this is the same town from the end of
season one where Dolores fully traversed
the maze and achieved full consciousness
the town itself is built to be a replica
of the original West world park from
years ago when Ford was first building
the hosts and they were first trying to
figure out what West's world would be
before they started building the other
parks there's still a lot of places that
we haven't seen in the park yet but we
do go back to that place from season 1
where they store all the dead hosts this
is actually the original
entryway where guests would arrive at
Westworld when they were first building
the park just meant to be more Easter
eggs for the west-world movies if you
haven't seen those movies in a while
number eight welcome back sighs more so
maybe is still kind of going through her
first version of the loop figuring out
that this is a fake reality construct
some of you may have figured out what
was going on before they revealed it
within the episode because you start to
notice some inconsistencies like why
didn't these old guards recognize her
because this was the guard that helped
her last time what's going on here does
he not like her anymore does he don't
wanna have anything to do with this you
don't really notice this Sizemore is
fake until he starts laying it on real
thick because he was famous for telling
really gaudy bad story so once they hit
the forge that's when it becomes really
obvious but number seven Bernard finds
Ashley in Fords secret lab he goes back
to the secret underground lair you see
all the other copies of Bernard that we
saw last season when they revealed that
he was the host but then you find out
that Ashley is also secretly been a host
that is one of the big fan theories
that's been happening since season one
dude because of the way they used the
character they kind of implied that he
was a host last season but they never
fully officially answered the question
until now so number six Ashley is a host
he reveals what his core programming was
Ford created him to protect Bernard and
allow him to escape the park and then
cover up all the evidence
then terminate himself so it was
actually built into his programming that
he was supposed to destroy himself later
they have that funny moment where
Bernard changes his programming again to
protect him so new core programming he's
gonna be going out into the real world
as they try to stop Dolores if he needed
my help you could have just asked so it
is funny that Ashley knows that he's
been reprogrammed Bernard also raises
the question about why Dolores brought
him back he thinks it's because Dolores
feels like she needs some checks and
balances so maybe she brought him back
to keep her from crossing the line but
maybe it's part of some bigger plan that
she has so number five Sizemore in the
forge are revealed as fakes as the
reality slowly starts to crumble because
Maeve starts taxing him too much they
explain this later when she gives them
the crazy math problem the version of
Sizemore that they built for this
construct is only built to do a couple
things so the more Maeve asks of him
more to question his reality the more
the constructs starts to break down
so she's inside a fake reality because
the west-world people or someone is
trying to examine her you don't find out
to the end of the episode why she was
inside this construct but they do remind
you that Dolores is the only person who
knows the coordinates of the forge all
that information with the backups of the
hosts in the people that were stored
that's where Dolores sent Eddie at the
end of last season so Dolores wants to
keep that safe because she still does
care about Teddy once made figures out
the size morphs fake she tells a couple
good jokes about him too like we know
this is fake because Sizemore was only
obsessed with himself like look at all
these pictures of me he would never
cared about me that much so number four
mave breaks the matrix with math
basically she just gives them a really
really difficult math problem to solve
that eventually starts compounding and
acts like this sort of black hole of
processing power that just sucks in all
the other fake texts from that reality
it gets pretty funny once they start the
ball rolling and then she also puts all
the maps inside the hosts pockets before
they go back for another loop so that
she can break the simulation even more
by taxing its processing power we're all
traders number three was that big
obvious Game of Thrones cameo scene she
just seems to get laid off
give the buyer what let's start up in
Costa Rica lucky hang at that because
during a piece so I talked about this in
my last video it was highly publicized
that the Game of Thrones producers Dan
and Dave would have a cameo during West
world Aztecs we just didn't know exactly
what it was going to happen the West
world producers explained that what they
wanted to do is because this is meant to
be medieval world that Bernard and
Ashley are walking through which is also
from the West world movies but this is
like West world playing it as if their
medieval world is based on the world of
A Song of Ice and Fire
I'm sure within the world of West world
they paid millions and millions of
license fees to the estate of George our
Martin to get the rights to those the
West world producers said the reason why
it was Dan and Dave the cameoed is west
world Tex is because they wanted to use
the drogon character model so it's
literally like they copy pasted it
drogon from Game of Thrones into West
world it's the exact same character
model but because it's HBO HBO
technically owns those assets so it's
really easy for them to clear something
like that if you listen really carefully
you can actually hear them talking to
each other about finding a buyer off an
island in Costa Rica for the dragon that
they created that's a big Jurassic Park
reference you could also think of it as
a Jurassic world reference you don't
really get a good look at their names
but they're actually credited as Dan and
Dave so within the world of West's world
these two texts are named Dave and Dan
they created a dragon and they're going
to be selling it to Richard Hammond
sometime soon Jurassic Park you all
remember is also a Michael Crichton book
so Michael Crichton wrote Westworld he
also wrote Jurassic Park so they're just
doing larger Michael Crichton Easter
eggs here you guys can let me know
whether you like this or whether you
didn't like it some people just felt
like it was really on the nose but
obviously back when West world first
debuted a lot of people were like
wouldn't it be cool if there was a game
of Thrones world but that was a couple
of years ago so I haven't really thought
about that since then number two Maebh
escapes the simulation within a
simulation by hacking another robot so
the cool thing about this is that you
actually get to see through the robots
perspective so it's almost like you're
playing some kind of video game just
watching it assess threats as it just
rips into riot mode takes or cortex and
just bust through all those guards
the way the robot goes out also answers
some questions about what's going on
with that final scene when she meets
CEREC - so number one obviously probably
one of the biggest parts of the episode
Maeve meets CEREC the creator of
Rehoboam sort of like an alternate
version of Ford who created this giant
machine to lead humanity forward and
literally create the future as he says
it is our job to create the future a
prophet only predicts it we created you
all probably recognize vincent cassell
i've never seen a movie or a TV show
with him in it where he doesn't play
some really arrogant smart person who
just talks over people so it'll be
interesting to see what happens to him
this season the way he's playing the
character is that he seems like he wants
to help humanity but there's this really
sinister overtone to it like he's
controlling humanity he knows what's
best so he's going to use this machine
to help lead humanity forward the reason
why I think he's able to freeze Maeve in
her tracks is because remember when we
saw the robot go down and her cortex
just rolled into the grass Ciroc would
have been the person to put her cortex
in a new physical body so he could have
added special code to protect himself
into that body that he put her in so
whatever he did to change her he now has
a fail-safe button to protect himself
which does seem like it's prudent given
that she tries to kill him immediately
but if you don't remember from last
week's episode the way they sort of
established him inside the insight
company is that he's one of the founders
kind of like Ford is one of the founders
of Westworld
when his business partner died and left
his assets to his son who we met in last
week's episode the person that Delores
was trying to pull a fast one on he
locked Liam out so he's the only one
that has access to Rehoboam and he says
that it's not working right anymore and
it's because of what Delores is doing
but so far we don't really know what's
going on only that he says there will be
no future if they continue on their path
in the whole thing about the Rehoboam
system is that it's designed to analyze
the future based on predicting people's
behaviors so it's sort of like the way
Doctor Strange was using the time stone
during Avengers infinity war to analyze
millions and millions of different
possible futures Rehoboam does that but
it's actually analyzing the potential
actions of all the other people that
it's plugged into or connected to
through their devices or through their
systems they use the last week's episode
to show you how human
relies on insights software and systems
so much that Rehoboam is literally
connected in governing all the people as
if they themselves were hosts trapped
inside a simulation in Rehoboam is the
thing that's giving them their marching
orders telling them what to do giving
them suggestions maybe you should do
this instead of that so this why serach
comes off as sort of a sinister figure
the same way that four does so I'll be
interesting to see how they position him
in the series versus four because Ford
actually seemed like he eventually
wanted to help everyone and really did
want to make things better
so everyone post all your predictions in
the comments below and let me know if
you think that Soraka is going to wind
up being an evil character or a good
character that will try to help them
episode three will post next week so as
long as you have alerts enable for my
channel you should see that video when I
post it every one click here for my West
world episode one video and click here
for my brand new Marvel Deadpool 3 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stays safe I'll see you guys tonight